( intro music )
( applause )
Trip Jennings: I was thinking
about what to say about risk
and why we take it,
preparing for this presentation,
and I remembered a moment
when I thought a whole lot
about that question,
"Why do we take these risks?"
I was dangling
from a very thin rope,
not a climbing rope
but a throw rope
that you use in a kayak,
trying to rappel
to the bottom of the
Pandi River Canyon
in the very remote jungles
of Papua New Guinea.
Here's a shot of the river
as it flows out of the mouth of
the Pandi River.
And the evening before,
I had had the most terrifying
experience
I've ever had in a river.
I was 100 feet down into
the canyon...
...when I reached the end
of my rope.
Still 40 feet
from the very bottom.
And, so, I had to wait
for like an hour
while my friends
walked through the jungle
to get some more rope
to lower down to me.
So, that was a
pretty good moment, right,
to kind of think about...
"Why do we take these risks?
How did I get here?"
And so,
we'd come to Papua New Guinea
to paddle the source
to sea descent of the
Pandi River.
Right, it was a river that had
never been explored in a kayak.
The reason
we'd chosen this river
was that it was slated
to be logged and clear-cut
for an oil palm plantation.
So we wanted to use
our adventure story
to tell a story about a culture
and ecosystem
on a brink of change.
We started at the
underground source of the Pandi,
deep in a cave.
And we made our way down
through some
of the most beautiful
and amazing white water
I've ever seen,
through some small waterfalls,
and some large waterfalls.
And towards the end of the day,
we got to a point where
the whole Pandi River
poured off of a 20 foot cliff
into this cauldron where all of
the water re-circulated back
upstream into a cave
behind the waterfall.
It was way too dangerous to run,
even though
it wasn't a big drop,
but it was
way too dangerous to run.
Because that's not
a good place to be;
behind a waterfall, stuck.
And so,
it was almost dark,
and the canyon walls were
100 feet vertical on all sides.
There's no way out but down.
That's the worst place you ever
want to be in a kayak, right?
That's like
every kayaker's nightmare.
And so we decided
what we would do,
is we would make our way
on to this small cliff
as far downstream as we
could on river right.
We'd hop in our kayaks
and slide off of the cliff
into the river
and if we did it just right,
we'd be downstream
of the upstream flow.
The re-circulation area.
We'd make it out all right?
So, I went forth
in the twilight, almost dark.
I caught--
It went fine.
I caught the very first eddy
that I could,
so I could stop and run safety
for Matt Fields-Johnson.
He was our photographer
on the expedition
and the least experienced member
of the crew.
And I watched him
slide off of the...
the sort of cliff,
the precipice there,
and watched his boat
turn sideways in the air,
land, flip
and get sucked upstream
behind the waterfall into,
kind of, the worst place to be.
And,
he rolled a few times,
lost his paddle,
flipped over again
and swam out of his kayak.
His kayak went downstream
and he was stuck
in this really turbulent pool,
barely able to breathe,
every now and then
getting a breath.
And, thankfully, Brian Eustis
was still on the cliff.
He hadn't gone yet.
He tried again and again
to toss him a rope, right,
to get him anything to help him
get out of that spot,
and he just couldn't because
the cliff was so overhung.
And so, after a few minutes,
Matt was fa--
was floating
face down,
totally out of air,
totally out of breath and
totally exhausted.
And I was watching
my friend Matt drown.
And I couldn't do
anything about it
because the current separated me
from where he was.
And so, at the very,
sort of, very last resort...
...Brian lowered
all of the rope.
He just tossed all of the rope
and held on to
the very end of it
and let it circulate around
and around in the pool
in that turbulent,
sort of, cave.
And finally,
a bit of it grazed
Matt's knuckles
and he grabbed--
grabbed the rope,
he pulled up on it,
he got a breath using his
last little bit of oxygen.
And, he and I had worked at
a summer camp for years
together and we had always
taught the kids,
"Oh, this is how you do this
cool trick knot,
a one-handed bowline,
and if you ever fall off
a cliff,
- with one hand on the rope...
- ( audience laughter )
...it'll save your life."
And so that was how we got
kids to get excited about it.
And we never-- We always
thought that was total BS.
- ( audience laughter )
- Until he pulled himself up,
threw one handed bow
and then fell back into the rope
and Brian was able
to pull him up just enough
and Matt clawed his way back up
onto the cliff, right?
And I was watching this with
my flash light at this point,
my head lamp,
because it was dark.
So, Matt passed out
from total exhaustion
just a few minutes later.
Well, sort of,
separated from his boat,
separated from his gear,
with nothing on
but his kayaking gear
to shiver and snuggle with Brian
all night long.
And... So the next morning,
the rest of our job
was, kind of,
to get up and around...
...to a place that we could
rappel down
into the river canyon.
Make sure that
he could swim safely,
run safety for him,
as he swam
across the river upstream
of the rapid
that had nearly killed him
the night before.
And so, that's where
I got to the end of my rope.
And I was sitting there
thinking to myself:
"How did I get here,
why...
why do we do this?"
And few of the reasons
that really...
...stuck out in my mind,
I think
are really important lessons
that I bring with me
on and off the river.
And I want to share a few,
a few of them with you.
So, when you are deciding
whether or not to
run a rapid, right?
That's one of the
most important decisions
you can make as a kayaker:
when to run and
when to walk around it.
And so, what I first want to do
is I want to look at
all of the hazards, right?
I want to look at all the things
that are terrifying
and dangerous about that,
that particular rapid.
Or maybe it's an expedition
or any risk you want
to take, right?
I want to look at the
dangerous things.
Look at the--
I want to know where they are,
what they are and
what they might do to me,
if I mess up
and how to get around them.
And I, kind of, like to hold
those things in my fear hand.
And then I like to think about
why I want to paddle this rapid,
right?
There's good reasons to do it.
I love being immersed in this
beautiful river
and working with it
to get myself safely
through a hard spot.
But there's also other reasons,
right?
Maybe we want to
impress our friends.
Maybe there's a really good
photographer on the trip
and you want to get
that awesome image.
Maybe you've got some
camera courage going.
And...
I like to think of those things
as, kind of, the ego
and I like to hold those things
separate, right?
So that I can, kind of,
acknowledge them
because they are there,
they are real,
they exist for all of us.
But I don't want them to be part
of my decision making process.
And so, once I've separated
those two out,
I've got a look inside.
I've got to, kind of, listen to
my gut and my intuition, right?
And say,
"Can you run this rapid safely?"
And...
there's this, kind of,
beautiful moment, right,
when you really decide,
when you are able to separate
out these things.
We like to say that
running hard white water
is 60 percent mental,
and 40 percent actually
being strong and paddling
and having it balanced
and knowing the strokes.
Because this is
a hard process to fake,
to really be honest
with yourself.
About why you want to do this,
and can you do it, right?
And so,
once you've reached that point
and you've really separated out
the fear and the ego
and you've checked in
with your gut,
there's this beautiful moment
of clarity
and, kind of,
freedom that I feel.
And it's kind of, it's this
euphoric and rare thing.
And as you take
that last stroke,
you paddle out of the eddy,
that stroke that commits you
into paddling a drop,
into a decision that you've made
wholly on your own
to run this,
to take this risk
and to paddle this rapid.
That's one of the
most empowering feelings
I've ever had
in any experience in my life.
Because that is where we really
unlock our true passion.
We unlock and, we sort of,
are able to get in touch with,
you know,
what makes us tick,
in our really--
our true potential.
We are able to do, you know,
what we are here to do.
And so, what I needed to do
at that moment
was get that rope
and get to the bottom
of the Pandi River Canyon,
which I did.
Matt was able to swim across,
no problem.
He got up, he got out.
We got him to his boat
and we paddled for the
rest of the week downstream
to complete the first source
to sea descent of the
Pandi River Canyon.
And, as I think about
that expedition,
and as I, sort of,
reflect on that,
I think it's clear to me now,
seven, eight years later
and many expeditions later,
that, you know,
I let that ego get in my way.
I really wanted the photos
that Matt would take
because he is a
great photographer.
And so I invited him
on an expedition
he probably wasn't ready for.
And...
You know,
I got him into a situation,
we all got into a situation,
that he couldn't get out of
on his own.
And almost paid
a really big price for that.
And that's something I,
kind of, carry with me
in my decision-making processes
in life
and on the river.
I think if I'm going to
risk my life
to tell a good story,
I want to make sure that that
story is really worth telling.
That means telling a story
that really helps us
as individuals,
and as a society,
decide how we want to relate
with each other
and with the ecosystems
that make life on this
Earth possible.
So, I hope that everybody will
challenge yourselves
to be risk takers
and make it to the end.
Make it to the sea.
Thanks a lot.
( applause )
( outro music )